amid a new warning of the dangers from
dr. Anthony Fauci in testimony from his
home office yesterday
he told the Senators that people may die
needlessly states continue to ease
social distancing rules before
coronavirus affection rates decline but
the vast majority of states are now
starting to reopen without following
white house guidelines many businesses
are taking precautions on their own but
others have been packed with people
there's already been a spike in new
cases in some areas with loosened
restrictions Nancy Cordes is on Capitol
Hill forests Nancy dr. foul she did have
some positive news about a vaccine which
we'll get to but what else did he have
to say well Toni the good news is that
foul she said vaccine development is
moving more quickly than initially
expected that we could see whether these
clinical trials have been successful by
late fall early winter in the meantime
though he argued that most states are
courting a second wave of cases by
reopening too soon my concern is that we
will start to see little spikes that
might turn into outbreaks speaking from
his home in DC dr. Anthony found she
told senators it's dangerous for states
to reopen before infection rates drop
there is a real risk that you will
trigger an outbreak you may not be able
to control he said the truth u.s. death
toll is likely higher than the official
count of more than 80,000 and he said a
vaccine will not be ready in time for
the fall semester at schools and
universities the idea of having
treatments available or a vaccine to
facilitate the re-entry of students into
the fall term would be something that
would be a bit of a bridge too far
still Kentucky Republican Rand Paul
challenged foul Chi's cautious stance
and as much as I respect you dr. Falchi
I don't think you're the end-all I don't
think you're the one person that gets to
make a decision I have never made myself
out to be the end-all and only voice of
this we don't know everything about this
virus and we really better be very
careful particularly when it comes to
children because the more and more we
learn we're seeing things about what
this virus can do
we didn't see from the studies in China
or in Europe all the witnesses and many
senators attended the hearing remotely
to reduce the risk of infection
Rhona there was bipartisan dismay in the
government's early response I find our
testing record nothing to celebrate
whatsoever a contrast to the president's
triumphant tone on testing the day
before
there's nobody close to us in the world
and we certainly have done a great job
on testing Connecticut Senator Chris
Murphy urged the task force to issue
more guidelines to States about
reopening when are we gonna get this
expertise from the federal government I
do anticipate these broader guidance
though to be posted on the CDC website
yeah soon
I can't soon isn't terribly helpful
Thank You mr. chairman
House Democrats released their massive
new rescue bill yesterday it's worth
about three trillion dollars with more
payments to state and local governments
to working Americans and more money for
testing the house is expected to vote on
it on Friday but Senate Republicans are
already rejecting it saying Anthony that
it's too expensive Nancy thank you